to oh God I hate this
is going everywhere
King Charles freaks out over a leaky pen
days after the death of his mother Queen
Elizabeth well this is a family
um in mourning now and um of course the
queen was a mother a grandmother and a
great grandmother it all went down
Tuesday when the Monarch visited
Hillsborough castle in Ireland with his
wife Camilla Queen consort and as he was
signing the Castle's guest book well
let's just say things didn't get off to
a stew pendous start
foreign
[Music]
yeah you can see the king's frustrated
so his wife steps in to try and help
me
[Music]
Charles we feel you nothing like a linky
pen to grind your gears
[Music]
following his mother's death Charles has
officially ascended the throne he could
have chosen to take a different name as
king he has chosen King Charles III as
the queen herself did with such
unswerving devotion
I too now solemnly pledge myself
throughout the remaining time God grants
me
to uphold the constitutional principles
at the heart of our nation the family
has since been in a Royal morning period
[Music]
Wednesday morning the Queen's body left
Buckingham Palace for the last time
mourners came out to see the historic
procession as her coffin traveled to
Westminster Hall walking behind the
Queen's casket were all her children
King Charles Princess Anne prince Andrew
and Prince Edward as well as her
grandsons Prince William and Prince
Harry
foreign
we know that this is a rift between the
Royal brothers that runs deep we notice
a rift that's caused the queen a great
deal of pain I suppose everyone will be
will be hoping that there can be some
sort of a Reconciliation the Queen's
funeral is set for September 19th and
it's expected that King Charles's
coronation will happen sooner rather
than later at present there is no
official confirmation of the timeline of
Charles's coronation but all the sources
who I have spoken to suggest that
Charles will have a coronation far
sooner than his mother's coronation
there was a full year between the death
of King George VI and the coronation of
Queen Elizabeth this is going to be much
shorter time period the Prince of Wales
has been our longest serving Prince of
Wales the longest King in waiting and I
expect that his coronation will be
certainly in a matter of months rather
than a year
foreign